et un des premiers hommes politiques à
réagir et le sénateur et l'ère des
yvelines et président du sénat gérard
larcher sur son compte twitter assassiné
pour avoir enseigné la liberté de penser
d'écrire de caricaturer assassiné pour
avoir enseigné que nous sommes une
société de liberté qui refuse le
fanatisme et la haine
je pense à la communauté enseignante et
à ses proches ne reculons plus ce matin
lundi 19 octobre dans le cadre de
l'ouverture du congrès des régions de
france dans l'hémicycle du conseil
régional de saint-ouen valérie pécresse
présidente de la région ile de france a
voulu rendre hommage à l'enseignant je
ne puis débuté notre séance sans
partager avec vous l'horreur que nous
inspire l'assassinât barbare du
professeur samuel pâtit samuel patty a
été égorgé par un terroriste islamiste
dans notre belle région d'île de france
à conflans sainte honorine il habitait
errani il enseignait l'histoire
géographie et c'était un homme de bien
le maire génération de trappes à lire ab
a déclaré également dans un tweet j'ai
juste la nausée pensée pour les proches
et les collègues de la victime et pour
finir dans un communiqué de presse
publié samedi 17 octobre le
rassemblement national des yvelines
apporte son soutien à l'ensemble du
corps enseignant et s'attaquent à
certains élus du département la
fédération des yvelines du rassemblement
national appelle les yvelinois a cessé
d'accorder leur confiance à ceux qui
depuis des années met en oeuvre des
politiques clientélistes et
immigrationniste qui favorise le
communautarisme et le séparatisme
terreau du terrorisme
fin de citation